[Music]
the american chestnut tree was one of
the most
abundant and dominant trees in the
eastern united states appalachian chain
[Music]
they were gorgeous trees it is actually
the tree that inspired the
christmas song chestnuts roasting on an
open fire
it was a very heavily used resource by
people
in the late 1800s people brought asian
chestnuts to north america as an
ornamental tree
and they carried with them a disease a
fungal blight
and it infected native american chestnut
trees
and just wiped them out completely over
99
of the population was obliterated
fast forward nearly 100 years and a team
led by william
powell at the state university of new
york was able to actually discover
why the blight kills the chestnut tree
and they have produced a strain of
chestnut trees that is 100
resistant to this fungal blight it
really shows that
there's no point of no return
there's potentially no point you can get
where you can't
end up recovering and healing the damage
that's happened
and that's the hope that biotechnology
brings to conservation
the un is issuing a dire warning on
climate change
nearly a million species are at risk of
extinction because of humans we are
doing
irreparable harm to earth's biodiversity
and what is clear is that we're driving
species to extinction
the human species has driven the
planet's biodiversity
into an unprecedented decline
the extinction rate is a thousand times
higher than it naturally would be
with as many as one million species at
risk
many scientists say we are in a sixth
mass extinction the decline in
biodiversity
is a crucial issue that is largely
overlooked in the public consciousness
in terms of how important it really is
our existence as humans
is deeply intertwined with the health
and flourishing of a number of non-human
species
if you destroy the environment it's
going to turn around and
bite back we need to radically rethink
our relationship to the natural world we
need to understand that we are
a deeply entrenched part of it certainly
not separate from it
this is part of what is killing other
species and eventually us too
traditional conservation methods alone
are struggling to offset the speed at
which we're losing species
and habitats biotechnologies that have
been developing in the wings
are now offering the hope of new if not
controversial
ways of saving endangered species
genetic rescue traditionally has been
the
the practice of increasing a
population's genetic diversity
um in a way to benefit it um usually
when the population is exhibiting some
type of problem like inbreeding or
whatnot
we're trying to increase genetic
diversity or increase the
viability of the genetics of a
population
then in that kind of very core
definition
biotechnologies offer a whole host of
ways to do that
biotechnology offers everything from
genetic insight to
restoring diversity with cloning or
technologies or doing gene editing to
aid disease resistance all the way to
that moon
shot of using all those technologies to
restore something like a woolly mammoth
or a passenger pigeon
the process of resurrecting species like
this is known as
de-extinction and it's one of the more
complex
and controversial applications of this
biotechnology
because of by the technology we can
bring back those kind of animals
but of course it is it is a tedious work
to do
but it is not impossible de-extinction
is a scientific movement we could say an
emerging space
of researchers who are trying to use a
variety of different biotechnologies
in order to help recreate
close approximate versions of extinct
species
so that they can create new animals that
mimic extinct species and can go back
out into the wild spaces where extinct
species used to roam
and carry out important ecological roles
there that have disappeared since
certain species went extinct
the very first example of de-extinction
if you call it that is the bucato which
is a
pyrenean ibex or kind of a mountain goat
the last bucardo died in spain
it was a single animal but they took
some cells from its ear
and preserved those and years later they
used those cells to
to clone a bucardo using a domestic goat
as the surrogate
so they they could create cells implant
an embryo and a goat and the goat gave
gave birth to a live
buccado the species was brought back
only to go extinct again just 10 minutes
later
due to lung defects the 2003
resurrection of the buccado remains the
closest that
anyone has gotten to true de-extinction
at least for now
in 2017 george church's woolly mammoth
project
captured the public's imagination and
brought de-extinction
back into conversation so de-extinction
is really just
a little bit of hybridization um
using ancient dna and some modern
synthetic dna
to achieve a goal of say cold resistance
or pathogen resistance
church hopes to adapt the genome of the
woolly mammoth's closest living relative
the asian elephant to include a number
of mammoth
traits in particular how to thrive in
the cold climate of the arctic
we are using the tools of paleogenomics
which is the ability to actually get dna
sequences
from those extinct species from hundreds
or thousands of years ago and
and look at their genetic code compare
it to their living relatives and start
to understand what are the unique
fragments of dna that made them uh do
what they did in the environment
two there's now something called gene
editing which is most famously done with
crispr cast 9.
it's in enzyme and rna combination that
basically is a
a homing system that allows scientists
to target
any region of dna in a living cell's
genome
and make a cut and then make an edit to
that area
so we could take the hemoglobin gene
in an asian elephant's genome and
cut it and overwrite in its place the
hemoglobin allele from a woolly mammoth
which will change how it bonds oxygen at
different temperatures
and that's something that george
church's lab has already done in
culture in a petri dish so it used to be
a big deal to make one precise change in
the genome of an animal
we've made 42 changes in pigs we now
have 2 000
adult pigs of that that are called
three-point version 3.0
that are used for organ donations and
that's being tested now in pre-clinical
trials that shows we can do 42
in a cell in a lab and then move the
nucleus into
an egg and and bring it to term
all the way to adulthood thousands of
times
so we want to do the same thing in
elephants which are a little bit bigger
than pigs
a little slower but otherwise should be
a very similar
procedure while altering the genome of
living animals
like the asian elephant could help bring
a version of extinct species back to
life
it could also help to rescue a species
which is itself
endangered we want something that has
all the advantages
of cold resistance possibly resistance
to pathogens like the
ehv virus that's uh almost extinction
level
uh harm to the asian elephant which is
an endangered species
so you can consider it a hybrid but it
also we can use synthetic biologies to
say
alter tusk length to avoid poachers
so there's a number of opportunities
here that that is not limited to
the extinction of genes church wants to
reintroduce his hybrids into the arctic
tundra
which he hopes will preserve an
environment that's crucial to storing
carbon science has proven de-extinction
is possible
and the environmental argument for doing
it is clear
yet questions still remain doing
de-extinction there's a whole lot of
unknowns
and especially when you you're trying to
think about a species like a woolly
mammoth that's been gone for thousands
of years
what are the prospects for being able to
put this back in the appropriate kind of
environment
does woolly mammoth habitat even exist
anymore
and if you go for very long extinctions
the further back you go the more
uncertainty the less we know about
species
and the less likely there is to be a
place for it now
the technical ability is outrunning our
ability to think about is this a
sensible or a useful
thing to do and this is concern that you
know if we're
dealing with something as fundamental as
the genetic makeup of species and
thinking about putting them back out
into the wild
you know the genies out of the bottle a
bit what does it mean to take the tools
from synthetic biology
and merge them with the more traditional
conservation biologists who are losing
the game
as we're you know also losing more
species can
really fruitful combinations be born
from this hybridization of knowledge
sets
and indeed it seems to be happening
there are interesting projects getting
off the ground when you bring these two
different ways of looking at nature
together
something that's engineerable and
something that's worth saving
you